and also a couple years ago I was in
rehab and it we I went to a rehab there
was like a small group so it was only 12
people
and there was a guy in the group he was
wearing a Maga hat and at the time I was
gung-ho like anti you know I mean I was
just like a bleeding heart liberal and I
was like in my head I was like I'm not
gonna talk to that guy by the end of the
thing him and I were very close and I
remember when we hugged each other
goodbye I I kind of got teary and I was
like dude I'll see you call me this and
that right and I realized we have way
more in common than not that's right I
mean and it also it was like the media
and it was like social media and all
that stuff pitting us against each other
and it's not even real we were so
similar in every way right it's like
it's like the jangling keys they there
there's people who want to keep
Americans apart yeah and it's like you
know watch this look over here well I'm
robbing the bank stealing you unblocked
yeah yeah yeah we're all looking at the
keys and you know not seeing that he
just stole the Tesla or whatever yeah
yeah and uh and we're all distracted by
hating each other
and then you know the kind of the
central organizing theme of my campaign
is
finding values that we have in common
rather than these little issues that
keep us apart
but how do you how do you change that
how do you change you know false
information online how do you change all
these or even how do we change ourselves
from being so easily attracted by the
dangling Keys like is there something
like inherent about why it's so easy to
kind of be distracted
well I you know my you know my what my
dad was campaign my dad was in really
the same position I am in many ways
because he was running against a war he
was running against the president of his
own party
he was running against an entire
infrastructure that was a power that was
aligned against them the unions were
against them the Big City Mayors were
against them the liberal press was
against them the uh
even the University students at that
time were against him because he was for
he was ending draft deferments and the
people who he had brought into power in
1968 years earlier were all working for
Johnson uh so they were against them and
but he was able to put together this
Coalition by just telling the truth to
people and telling them truth that they
didn't want to hear and he went against
all the kind of uh political wisdom of
you know you have to tell people they
want to hear and he would
he would go to colleges like Creighton
University in Nebraska and tell and the
students asked him are you going to keep
our draft deferments that was the reason
most kids were in college because they
didn't want to go to Vietnam and he said
no I'm not going to because it's unfair
at 50 percent of every paratrooper a
unit in Vietnam is black because they
can't they don't have access to the
college
he said I can get my 11 kids into
um and get them out of the draft that
means that the words can be fought by
black people alone and that's not you
know results and and so he got booed at
first but then at the end he'd get a
standing ovation
and he did that all over the country
telling people news that they didn't
want to hear and as it turns out it
worked the last day of his life
he won the most rural state in the
country South Dakota and the most Urban
State and when you know when I was you
know when we rode on that train and
brought his body from I was with him
when he died and then we brought his
body
um uh Penn Central New York the Union
Station Washington it was a two and a
half it should have been a two and a
half hour train ride it was a seven hour
train ride because the tracks were lined
with people and the people with the
whole cross section of Americans they
were whites and blacks and people in
military uniforms hippies
and he had you know on rabbis and and
Priests and nuns I remember going
through Delaware and seeing seven nuns
standing in the back of a pickup truck
outside of Wilmington
waving the rosary beads at us and
it was this entire cross-section of the
American experience that he had been
able to unite
really by telling people the truth and
instead of appealing to their anger and
their greed and their xenophobia and in
a bigotry
he had tried to remind them of you know
the hero that's inside of all of us and
that were part of a community and that
we've got to resist the seduction of the
notion that
the only way to advance ourselves as a
people is by leaving our poor brothers
and sisters behind that we have to go
together together and people you know
people were willing to put aside to
transcend their narrow self-interest and
see themselves as part of a larger
community and a noble adventure and
I think we have to get back to that
vision of bringing Americans together
the Trump people you know and as you
said
when you start talking to people you
find all these things we have in common
and and part of the censorship regime is
to keep us from talking to each other
yeah it was the first time where I I was
like no I just want him to stay close
I am trying to I thought you were doing
the emo thing again
[Laughter]
well yeah I mean that's I mean yeah ever
since I met that dude right I want to
say his name but um the the mega guy
that was in my rehab it's opened my eyes
because then I went to
um Dollywood everyone went to Dollywood
and in my mind I was like it's an
amusement park it's where is it in in
Tennessee right right and I'm like a
Korean loudmouth kind of a you know I
mean crazy comedian and I went in there
and it was just there was just love
there yeah even for me yeah yeah and
these are people that probably generally
vote right or whatever but I felt like
this kinship with people and I just kind
of went you know what dude I'm not I I
think I'm gonna change my whole world
view on this thing yeah well there's the
internet and there's just real life yeah
yeah internet vitriol even us podcasting
for as long as we have it's like there's
that and you go out into the world and
you're like I'm not hearing you know
like insults thrown at me all day yeah
people are generally decent that's true
hard-working and kind yeah yeah and
inherently good I think yes so how do we
get so what what happens now I mean you
because I don't know much about politics
here I'm going to ask a dumb question no
okay so is during the you're running on
the in the Democratic primary what
happens how do we do this how do you get
how does Biden step aside oh yeah and
then is there a debate yeah yeah is
there a debate how does